hello everyone and welcome to the second
game that finished in the feeder
candidates tournament 2022 it's uh
fabiana carwana versus hikaru nakamura
the uh clash that uh well i believe
everyone was very much looking forward
to fabiana corona as the former world
church championship challenger and
hikaru who basically gave up on playing
cal a classical chess now uh he is here
in the candidates tournament and he is
uh well here to show that he can also uh
brawl it out with the best of them in
classical chess so it's quite a game
that features two really awesome
positive video moments so i hope you
guys will enjoy that uh let's dive
straight into it we've discussed the
tournament details in the previous video
uh if you haven't seen it do check it
out it's also quite in the game and also
a very nice
uh perhaps a decisive one now uh fabi
has the white pieces and he opens with
e4 with e5 by hikaru knight to f3 knight
to c6 and the bishop to b5 fabi prepared
the real opus for the candidates uh and
he car plays knight to f6 he goes for
the berlin defense because whoever lost
a game uh with the berlin defense uh
with d3 and bishop to c5 with uh bishop
captures and c6 the characters and the
knight beat the d2 so this is uh very
very standard um
nothing new happening here if you are
wondering why not capture the pawn uh
this would blunder the game queen d4
attacks the knight and threatens
checkmate so i really hope none of you
were considering that so after the
captures on c6 knight beat to d2 and
here at bishop to e6 just continuing
development we have castles and now
bishop to d6 now as uh the the king
castle safety this is now uh definitely
a threat so he covered defends it
and now knight to b3 uh interestingly
instead of knight to b3 there are also
other moves that are played in this
position for example ahikaru had this
exact same position with the white
pieces against wesley so in the 2020
senate lewis blitz tournament attended
in a draw in that game hikaru went with
the uh with the early d4
or with the delayed d4 basically the
early delayed d4
but even though it is the most uh
most played move here here fabi plays
knight to b3 he doesn't want to clarify
the situation in the sen in the center
right away uh he's playing against the
berlin defense in the candidates of
course he wants uh to have at least a
little bit of chance of winning uh you
know not just going to some familiar
lines so queen to e7 and now knight to
a5 asking hikaru what are your plans
with the king do you want to castle
queen side and then we have castles on
opposite sides of the board so it's
going to be a
really really crazy attacking game where
we can just start pushing pawns on the
queen side and on the king side uh who
who who is faster uh to
approach the opponent's king
before the other guy
and or do you want to play something
else and here he carl played a move that
has never been played before he car
played rook to b8 and it really is a
weird looking move uh it's just uh
defending the b7 pawn and it's saying
your knight on a5 is just stupid that's
you know plain and simple uh
what are you gonna play so it is now
already as of move nine that we have a
completely new game in the berlin
defense which is incredible in itself so
here bishop g5 fabian continues
development with h6 bishop to h4 and now
g5 hikaru not afraid to uh
expand those pawns on the king side
bishop to g3 and now knight to d7 the e5
pawn is attacked so of course we have to
defend it we have knight to d7 and now
f6 uh maybe some maybe later on f5 can
be played so d4 and hikar defends it
with f6 here berlin is one of those
openings where it's definitely okay to
play f6 in most lines queen to d3 fabie
develops the queen connects the rooks
and now pawn to h5 hikaru very
comfortable with the king in the center
threatening h4
which will pose a lot of problems for
for white so d captures an e5 we have
knight captures on e5 and the bishop
captures on e5 we have f captures on e5
now hikaru uh does have this weird
looking bishop on d6 for the moment it's
basically a pawn but he can play maybe
king d7 maybe bring the rook into the
attack maybe push g for h4 so the
position has a lot of attacking
potential uh so here at knight to c4 by
fabi putting pressure on the on the
bishop here and uh while you could play
bishop captures on c4 i think hikaru
really wants uh fabi to capture on d6 so
he can play uh undouble his pawns
improve his pawn structure uh but bishop
captures on c4 is uh
definitely very interesting the point is
after queen captures uh we can play king
to d7 and now after let's say a movie is
played rook 8 to d1 we're going to play
rogue beat to f8 and now start pushing
on the
on the king side and our king is uh
relatively safe here on d7 we want to
bring it to c8 at some point and um well
it it doesn't look
bad for black but but it's also
perfectly fine for white so instead we
have rook to d8 by hikaru now aligning
the rook with the queen basically asking
fabi to capture on d6 and he does we
have knight captures and c captures on
d6 and now hikaru uh fixed his pawn
structure and he says okay maybe later
on i can play something like this in the
attack on the king side but that's
exactly where the most interesting part
of this game happens
uh fabi plays queen to e3 uh attacks the
g5 pawn twice and also puts pressure on
the a7 pawn so g4 first we're gonna
attack the knight save the pawn uh from
being captured on g5 knight to d2 and
now pawn to a6 uh not uh not allowing
fabi to capture this pawn and now pawn
to b3 that's a very very cool move
because uh let's say f4 which is uh
which is the engine stop recommendation
uh you you are forcing black to capture
either by f captures uh e captures on f4
or by g captures an f3 alpha because you
do not want to see f5 on the board so
let's say g captures an f3 knight
captures h4 it's a fine looking position
but also black is definitely enjoying
this so fab instead says i'm going to
play b3 this will prevent your bishop
from capturing the a2 pawn once i
activate my rook but also after c4 i
will have a complete uh
grip on the position the center will be
mind control and if i can survive this
pawn push on the on the king side uh
white should be much better here so here
uh hikaru makes a very very weird
decision like uh like we said uh here h4
really it
looks very interesting point is that
after f3 which is kind of what you want
to play or f4 let's say f3 we're gonna
capture and after knight captures now
you play king d7 bring the rooks into
the attack and we get the position that
we discussed but uh here i believe uh
hikar plays a move that no one could
predict that he would play he actually
castles king's side and this is uh
uh perhaps uh perhaps it's playable but
it it does not seem to be in the spirit
of the position uh because now fabi is
not afraid of opening up the queen side
or the king side if fabio opens up the
king side he will use his rooks to
attack hikaru's king
so here f3 he goes for it right away at
queen to g7 by hikaru and now f captures
on g4 fabi very happy with opening up
the king side h captures and now rook
ate the d1 this is a very important
movie if you play something like c4
which really seems like a fine
positional idea
hikaru could even make moves like rook
to f4 and now the the rogue being on a1
is a problem uh you can't capture on f4
we can easily double up on the f file
it's uh for example captures captures
now the queen is hanging the rook is
hanging and once you defend uh the rook
we can play queen d4 check we can now
start pushing the pawns it's uh much
better for black so instead rook eight
to d1
and now pawn to d5 hikaru doesn't want
to wait for c4 and then uh you know fabi
just completely owning the the center of
the board so he strikes in the center
with d5 he says okay
now my presence is is definitely felt uh
but uh fabi welcomes this as he will
undermine those pawns so captures
captures rook d to e1 now threatening
the e5 pawn pawn to e4 and now uh we
have rook captures an f8 rook captures n
pawn to c4 this is how fabian undermines
the center and uh how do you defend of
course c captures on b5 is coming and
then the pawn on e4 is just weak and
here hikaru perhaps defends it a bit
passively he plays rook to e8 queen to
f6 is a is a very fine move uh
in trying to defend this position
because after sea captures and bishop
captures uh you can't capture the pawn
the pawn is not now safe because white
definitely has problems here if you if
you persist uh we're just going to
capture and after queen captures we're
going to play this check king moves and
now we're going to sacrifice the queen
for checkmate captures captures
encounters this will be checkmate so
instead after c4 he carl plays rook to
e8 this will uh add another defender to
the td for pawn but the position is not
a bit more passive so c captures on d5
bishop captures and now knight to f1 of
course you can't capture but then you
just uh i mean
you you simply don't do this so knight
to f1 here fabi cannot bring the knight
to g3 then to f5 or h5 or even move the
queen and then bring the knights to e3
and then put pressure on the position
all depending basically on what hikaru
plays so here queen to e5 and now queen
to h6 freeing up the e3 square for the
knight and hoping to somehow get it all
the way at f5 because that's basically
game over
uh so here queen to g7 offering uh a
queen trade uh an interesting uh idea
would be rook to e7 because look at this
uh
there's a lot of pressure on that h2
pawn okay the knight is defending it
but white would have to be very very
very careful but there's always this
rook to c1 idea going after this check
and once we prevent this bishop to e6
now we can even play rook to e1 and now
we have all sorts of uh nasty ideas here
like queen to g6 check picking up the
pawn
as this rook is now very much useful
here but okay uh hikaru goes queen to g7
right away offers a queen trade now
comes queen to d6 fabi welcomes this
extra tempo as the bishop is now hanging
bishop the c6 and the knight to e3 this
was the tempo
that uh was used uh uh to activate the
knight via the e3 square uh and now yes
g3 was played that's the position from
the thumbnail that's why the arrow was
there
but um
it's uh not not the the greatest of
moves uh but there really isn't a good
move here rook to f8 is one move that
could be played but uh still
if you move the rook away from the
defense of the e4 pawn uh could be uh
could be problematic uh but here g3 was
played by hikaru he wants to save his
pawn because the pawn is hanging g3 was
played and now he's hoping for maybe
queen captures on g3 but of course uh
you you will not see that
there is a move that is completely
crushing fabi can just win the game uh
out right here but it's an incredibly
difficult one to spot so feel free to
pause the video here and try to
try to figure this out while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting h captus
and g3 that is the move that fabi played
but there is an even stronger one so
whoever found rook to f1 you are a
stronger player than fabiano corona that
is the truth because rook to f1 black
can just resign
you know sounds weird but uh look at
this h captures uh g captures on hd
checking to h1 now how are you
preventing the knight from coming to f5
you can play rook to f8 okay it helps a
little bit but still knight f5 and now
how do you defend uh if you play a weird
move with the queen like queen f7 we
just deliver a check you know
that's game over so you really don't
have a good move here if you play
something like queen to f6 uh you can
play this but uh
it's not it's not great queen to g3 with
cher king f7 now knight h6 check uh
black resigned so here you really have
no moves so basically after knight to f5
uh your only option is to play e3 try to
give up the queen for for some
counterplay but it doesn't work we can
simply capture the queen after rook
captures king captures an h2 king
captures on g7 if you play if you push
the pawn then just one check uh and we
pick up the pawn e2 square is not
guarded so we have to give out the pawn
king captures queen e7 check king
anywhere it doesn't really matter queen
captures an e3 and you have some
compensation but it will not uh be
enough white will win this so that's uh
that's the way to go uh rook to f1
however favi played after this g3 move
played h captures and g3 which is also
fine it's just not as quick uh and also
uh you know it requires you to play a
lot a lot of uh very very precise moves
and it will give hikaru uh
chances in this game to bounce back so
here queen to e5 now he ruined fabi's
pawn structure and now he wants to trade
queens to go go for an end game yes he's
down a pawn but it's a double g pawn uh
hikaru says i can hold this uh fabi goes
queen g6 check we have queen to g7 and
now queen to d6 we have queen back to e5
repeating the position a little bit uh
it's moved 36 so both players of course
are very much interested in reaching
time control uh queen to h6 and now uh
hikaru has to decide whether whether
it's okay to grab a pawn if he can grab
a pawn and survive you know it's equal
material perfectly fine or does he want
to play something like rook to f8 and
you know completely disregard the pawn
he goes for queen captures on g3 and
it's uh
it's it's it's a fine move but it um
his position did not improve he just uh
he he he just
grabbed the pawn
uh and now uh fabi can finally play that
rook to f1 move which he does rook to f1
and now the knight is coming to f5 the
queen here covers the knight so don't
have to worry about that
we have queen to g7 offering a queen
trade and now we have queen to h4 uh or
if you try queen to d6 and now try to go
for f5 we can try queen to a7 again we
defend uh now comes queen to f4 and okay
this is again i perfectly winning for
white knight is coming to f5 so hikaru
cannot prevent this but okay uh fabi
went queen to h4 now we have queen to h7
and here uh there was a lot of
discussion because uh that that's what i
meant uh that rook to f1 was uh much
much quicker than uh the move uh fobby
played h captures on g3 is because here
hikaru has a move that really makes it
uh incredibly difficult for fabi to win
but it's uh not an easy one to find so
uh you could try to to spot it if you
don't know the move uh feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
move that perhaps holds the position for
hikaru while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it and especially who did the
previous one as well congratulations you
should be playing in this tournament and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is bishop the d7 that's the
move uh controlling these uh these fine
squares uh and now there's only one way
for fabi to go uh and try and win this
and that is knight to f5 now okay you
have to capture this bishop captures
rook captures threatening rook g5 to win
the queen but now rook to e5 and now
have you defended successfully uh not
really queen to d8 with check king the
h7 and now rook to f4 going for rook to
h4 check uh so rook to h5 but not we
just play rook captures on e4 so you've
managed to
survive not being checkmated but you've
lost this pawn and now you will uh well
it's still not easy rook to e7 is
another big threat we're gonna win the
queen here so you have to go for let's
say queen a1 check and now can you get
some sort of a perpetual no you can't
king to f2 rook to f5 check king g3
queen to g7 with check and now not king
h2 but rather king h3 this is the move
that
keeps the game going for white rook h5
check and finally rook to h4 queen to c3
with check we're gonna block now g3 and
now you have to trade captures and
captures and now you have this queen and
pawn end game uh where white is up upon
now whether fabi would be able to win
this against hikaru uh who knows
probably yes uh
you know he would torture him forever
and you know at some point probably win
uh but this was hikaru's best chance so
congratulations uh to all of you who
found this this was an incredibly
resilient move to find uh but it's a
move 39 so we're one move away from time
reaching time control and uh you know
it's a very very difficult move to find
uh
you know on demand so here uh hikaru
played queen to h7 but now it's just uh
yeah straight up winning for for uh
fabi queen to g3 with check uh queen to
g7 queen back to h for with check and
now uh bishop to d7 so uh fabi fabi
misses the instant winning idea instead
of after queen to h7 uh
sorry after queen to h7 you have to play
queen to f4 that's how we uh ensure that
the knight gets to f uh
f5 in time uh and also we just prevent
rook to f8 so there will not be any move
here but it's also move 40 for fabi he
played queen to g3 check again he allows
his car to maybe bounce back a little
bit queen g7 now queen to h4 again queen
to d6 is the is the correct idea but
this is one one uh crazy scramble queen
h4 and now uh hikaru plays bishop to d7
so now it's a very very similar position
and uh it seems fabi should go for
knight to f5 he missed it
in that line that we've discussed but
now he kind of has to play it and uh
there's no other move to play this but
here we have rook to d1 by fabi again
allowing hikaru to
maybe bounce back uh but hikaru just uh
loses the game here he plays bishop to
e6 and this is not the way to go uh the
true move that holds the position is
rookie seven and now uh it seems that uh
you are defending the bishop
there's no way to do anything the bishop
controls the f5 square so there's no
good way to activate the knight the
bishop and queen control the g4 square
so here black seems to be holding
however after bishop to e6 this is the
third and final pause the video moment
and it's not an easy one to find
i know i said there were gonna be twos
and there are actually three uh
sometimes i even surprised myself you
know during these videos uh but yeah
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this one it's it's really a nice
one
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on beating hikaru
nakamura in the feeding candidates
tournament and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is not queen
captures an e4 it is actually knight to
d5 that's that's the move so truly
congratulations if you found all three
positive video moments uh you know uh
true truly hats off to you uh you are an
amazing player now the problem is why
you can't play this is because queen g5
this is what hikaro found and now yeah
bishop to f7 is just a terrible threat
the the knight will will suffer the
queen is also aligned with the rook so
this would definitely hold the game for
black but after knight to d5 how are you
defending against knight to f6 check uh
one way is to capture the knight but
then how are you defending rook g5 if
rook to e6 we play rook to the queen d8
okay the idea is okay we can block rook
g5 with rook g6 but queen v8 chuck king
h7 now queen to h4 with check rook to h6
and now queen captures an e4 with check
we grab this pawn with tempo rook g6 and
now rook to h5 check king g8 and finally
queen to e8 check and that's it you have
to block and we pick up the rook game
over uh so that that's the problem so
hikaru can't really capture the knight
here uh he plays rook to f8 which is the
only way to continue the game and it is
the best movie in indeed
but now queen captures an e4 now fabi
grabs a pawn and uh the position is very
very difficult to play queen to h6 by
hikaru and now just rook to e1 attacking
the bishop hoping for for a trade here
rook to d8 uh putting pressure on the
knight here and now just knight to e7
with check so and now there is nothing
more hikaru can do king f7
knight to f5 finally the knight finds
its way to the f5 attacking the queen
here uh it doesn't really matter if you
play bishop captures an f5 we can just
play queen to e7 with check and we pick
up the rook and you know it's completely
winning even just by material uh so
instead the queen to f6 was played by
hikaru but now rook f1
we have brush from d5 attacking the
queen now knight h6 check and that's it
there is uh
nothing more you can do here king the g7
and now we have queen to g4 check and he
was in this position on move 50 that
hikaru nakamura resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
once you block okay if you capture if
you capture the knight of course we
capture the queen with check and if you
block then there's the amazing knight to
f5 check king the h7 and the now queen
to h4 check and look at this the only
square for you for your king is the g8
square of course you can also blunder
your queen but after king h8 now we can
play 97 check become the queen we can
capture the rook with check uh we can do
whatever we want and it's it's just a
beautiful position so of course hikaru
does not want to see this on the board
after queen g4 check he resigned and a
wonderful wonderful victory for uh
fabiano corwana in round one of the 2022
phoenix candidates tournament so so far
we've uh
we've seen two games uh yanni pognishi
uh wins and fabiana corwana wins so the
the the players that already challenged
magnus for the title uh grab their wins
in round one of defeated candidates
tournament we'll see how it continues
we're going to cover probably at least
one more game from round one uh maybe
even more uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it really really a
wild one sorry these um uh feeding
candidates uh videos might be a bit
longer because they are so well prepared
the guy not the videos but uh the the
players are so well prepared for the
games that they
really play very very complicated lines
and uh it really uh i i think pays off
to check out most of the nicer ones so
hope you guys don't mind mind that
uh yeah so really hope you enjoyed that
uh i would like to thank some industry
yeah david kimura david just look
nagarjuna
and ks dillon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day